I'm not going to sit on my counter I'm
not coming arbitrary thunders that would
have been fun to write yeah isn't your
night taker the whole family like this
literally
[Music]
which role of your co-stars would you
like to have stolen oh I watching you
float around in space and your underwear
I didn't know if I could have had the
courage and I just have to every but I
loved what you only wear pretty much
pretty much that was a good night
Benjamin buttons I love that movie my
god so much it was so beautiful and I
think that film I would have liked to
have been in there's a lot of oh I would
have stolen Helena in wings of the death
see this is the thing if you're gonna
steal someone else's role you'd better
be sure you could do it like I could be
cakes not myself but I want to be Kate
in
NPS shout out to practical magic
[Music]
you want me to sing
what if we could make all this go away
I get my watch back please sorry okay
most likely to get sick but elegantly in
honored sandy I mean walking tissue yeah
I was my kids just kept regurgitating
and we always just yeah the cast on my
finger and it was just we're just gonna
go out on that mount also a walking
pharmacy so if anyone else hadn't but
natural homeopathic it's like this this
not a drug I mean no no I walk acquired
by clean has been for years yeah she's
come in like really in your face yeah
yeah barf drugs broken finger hashtags
and herbal before you know this is
mommy's very special work trip which one
of the your co-stars roles would you
like to steal yeah I would probably
Kate's Elizabeth probably read something
I'd like to steal have had the
opportunity to do never could possibly
do what she did at all but that would be
a goodie I think I'd do Kate's blue
Jasmine but like in combination with in
repertory wins lives do what's yours
yeah because I saw her do Blanche DuBois
in streetcar yeah and they were both so
so incredible so if I can he you know
blue Jasmine in the morning sailors take
warning do Rihanna's role in the video
for a rude boy she's a very jungle
tribal theme yeah I would do that I
played I don't see and no one would want
to watch it I've known also shout-out to
my badge
oh yeah Oh which sounds like really
different when I'm sure to your vag I
think collectively you can probably get
every single one in this movie to give a
shout out to your bags
yeah yeah your badges having a stellar
morning we did them and entry introduced
a screening last night and Nora said
like she just we all have said something
in front of the audience and Nora
grabbed the mic and she was talking
about she's like how great it was to be
there and she says something like
because because I'm not special and I
turned my badge makes you special and I
was kind of anticipating a laugh and
then I didn't and it was crickets and
I'm like definitely clear that over all
hundred million dollars can't we just go
to this did we have to steal stuff yes I
I was thinking about this movie and
about how everybody loves like playing
up feuds between women and how it's such
[ __ ] right what was like the bonding
moment for y'all I don't remember having
a specific one distinctly I just
remember feeling comfortable and not you
know I wasn't necessarily expecting to
feel at ease right away and I really did
there was of course up the post election
morning that we were all in the trailer
together and that was a kind of profound
thing to experience but sure with a
trailer full of women yes my first
morning that was your first first
morning on the so we all had our makeup
put on and we were all ready to go and
then Hillary was speaking and was giving
their kinsfolk concession speech and and
to the movies credit cuz I can't think
event many movies that would do that
they understood that like we all needed
to walk yeah and so we watched cried off
our makeup and they put it back on and
then we worked about 20 hours that was
that was a bonding day go
sometimes the best stories come when
there's a very dysfunctional personality
that makes for memories but when people
ask us for like what are the stories it
was just a very nice yes and so it so
that always happens because there wasn't
really that personality there was a
person or eight or a dynamic that was
toxic or anything so we don't have juicy
stories sometimes well no we actually do
have juicy stories but they're all
x-rated Oh tired and filth and we cannot
talk about them yes no no for sure we
have those stories we'd we'd you to have
the stories of just being like
and Chad thinks that she can stand on my
mark - Oscars you think you can see
where everyone it's a - fun
[Music]
[Music]